so what's happened in the jobs market
over the last 18 months is perhaps one
of the greatest curiosities of this
crisis normally at times of recession we
see unemployment spiking we see
vacancies falling right down although
unemployment has been kept relatively in
check vacancies have actually behaved in
entirely the opposite way to what we
might have expected just this morning we
heard vacancies in september up record
highs again over 1.1 million and
although that might seem like good news
on the surface for workers the reality
might be a bit more nuanced and there's
big challenges for business about how to
realign to the new reality post pandemic
so first of all have a look at this what
we're plotting here is some of the the
key sectors that are driving that big
growth in vacancies up there at the top
transport and logistics we've heard so
much about it haven't we up 300 job
adverts there on what they were pre
pandemic but problems in other sectors
too manufacturing construction even
travel and tourism surprising perhaps
given the problems that that sector has
faced
uh however that's not the case uh in all
sectors across the economy have a look
at this we've plotted here is some
sectors where job vacancies are actually
down on what they were before the
pandemic some of this might not be that
surprising for example sales we know
retail has had some problems but some
sectors here are a little bit surprising
jobs down in energy jobs down in legal
graduate jobs down as well and what's
essentially showing us is that there's a
realignment going to be happening in the
economy we know for example don't we
that there can be fewer jobs in places
for example like city centre sandwich
shops more jobs in places like
warehouses it may be a bit too soon to
see some of these things really playing
out in the data but some of the early
signs are certainly interesting now the
question for many of us is not just
where are the jobs but actually where
are the workers to fill all of these
vacancies and it's quite interesting
they might not necessarily always be in
the right places so what we've done here
is charting the number of unemployed and
furloughed people as of july against the
number of
regions of the country so essentially
the higher up they are on this graph the
more unemployed and furloughed people
there were as of july the further along
they are uh the greater growth in
vacancies that those sectors have seen
what this essentially shows there's
different problems in different regions
london for example right up there at the
top absolutely the worst place to be in
the country right now if you're a worker
by far the highest number of people
potentially looking for work the fewest
vacancies over at the other side
different problems the north east at the
largest number of vacancies there
yorkshire and the humber where we are
today higher vacancies and comparatively
fewer people looking for those jobs so
not only might the workers not be in the
right places but they might not also be
at the right skill level have a look at
this there is a slight correlation
between the number of vacancies in
certain sectors and the average earnings
in those sectors so over at this side
hospitality many more vacancies lower
pay on average over there on the other
end finance worth saying anecdotally
transport up there the big vacancies
driver anecdotally we do know that some
of the jobs that do exist are in those
lower paying driving jobs as opposed to
the managerial jobs as well and look as
we go forward over the coming years and
the coming decades there will be other
new challenges for businesses as well i
want to leave you with this one of the
challenges we may all face is automation
what this essentially shows is that
there is a direct correlation uh
anecdotally between
how likely a sector was to furlough its
workers in the recent crisis and how at
risk that sector might be from
automation so look up here at the top
food and tourism retail construction to
a degree as well highly likely to have
furloughed their workers during this
crisis much more at risk of automation
over here on the opposite end media
scientific i.t of course it won't go
unnoticed that these tend to be the
higher paying careers as well
potentially a slightly lower paying over
there so we big questions for businesses
not just about how these factors all
collide are we creating more vulnerable
group of workers going forward but
crucially also how business is going to
rise to this challenge and we'll be able
to find the workers that are needed